Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
attack on titan season 4 episode 7 video there
were a bunch of easter eggs and obviously this
is the full battle whereas last week we just
got the introduction so we'll break it all down
if you're new to the channel i'm doing videos
for all the attack on titan final episodes so
be sure to subscribe to get everything i know
there's a big question on how many final episodes
there'll be because there's only 16 listed on the
wiki right now they'll probably be more than that
but i'll talk about that during the video careful
for spoilers if you have not seen the episode yet
there were so many moments so i'll just number
these as we go along and talk about this shot
by shot but the episode picks up immediately in
the moments of the end of last week's episode
with porco trying to bite Eren's attack titan
with his jaw titan flipping out when he realizes
that it doesn't work remembering that levi had
slashed his jaw to prevent him from doing exactly
that then the horror on his face as he realizes
what's coming for him wait why aren't they afraid
of me i'm a titan they're just regular humans
wait a second those are the devils of parodies and
we finally get to see levi after a long absence at
the beginning of season four but in the very
short amount of time that has passed between
Eren starting his attack in right now pikas had
the time to join the fight fully loaded up in
her cart titan machine gun gear the important
thing about this too is that pique has way more
experience in battle as the card titan so she's
got a much cooler head about all this while porco
is busy crapping his titan pants if titans did
wear pants like later during the battle you see
her tell him to just slow his roll like hold on
here we have everything taken care of the thing
about that though big twist obviously they're just
twists within twists within twist in this episode
because the titan warrior unit isn't operating
on all the information there's a lot of stuff
going on here in this battle that they don't
know about so they just think that they have
the advantage Eren yeager is still battling it
out with willie tiber's sister and her warhammer
titan control crystal and we see that even though
her diamond strong protective cocoon is just like
andy's from the female titan unlike annie's she's
fully conscious the whole time and can monitor the
battle from inside but because she's immobilized
inside the crystal she can really only react
using her eye so like you can see how much she's
freaking out at any given moment based on her eye
movements she does prove that she does have
some skills when she's able to regenerate
another warhammer titan while she's being held by
Eren and is able to immobilize the attack titan
just as zeke finally enters the battle in his
beast titan you do wonder though where he was
just a minute ago when Eren killed willie tiber
and threw down with a warhammer titan the amount
of time that has passed though between the end of
episode 5 when he shifts into his attack titan in
episode 6 episode 7 is very short so you have to
assume that maybe only like 10 to 15 minutes has
probably passed between Eren activating his attack
titan in front of reiner and falco and then right
now when zeke is walking in but he did curiously
disappear for just a hot minute so remember that
there's a lot of stuff going on here a lot of four
dimensional chess being played during this battle
all the marlian forces all the other titan
warriors get hyped up to see him walk in
because he's such a badass in the beast titan
and he's highly skilled with his titan powers
they're all trying to kill Eren and take the power
of the founding titan for marley mcgath is still
trying to see their plan to completion his secret
plan that he made with willie tiber was to hype
Eren yeager up as the great villain of humanity
all nations not just marley because marley had
long been fighting wars with other nations but
they were slowly losing their advantage in battle
given to them by the titans other nations were
developing anti-titan weapons and would eventually
be able to defeat them also willy wanted to do
something about the ldn refugees living in marley
so there were a lot of different loose ends that
he was trying to tie up in their big secret plan
it is a way to ensure lasting peace resolve all
those different problems he planned with magath to
unite everyone in common cause around the world
all the different nations against Eren yeager
that's why he gave that whole big speech telling
the story about the true history of the titan war
then told everyone the threat that Eren posed
with the rumbling in the founding titan their
plan there as it's happening right now was then to
have a marlin hero visibly kill Eren have everyone
see a marlin kill Eren and that was supposed to
be mcgath which they thought would turn him into
another legendary hero that everybody loved around
the world and because they were going to let Eren
destroy the former marley and military leadership
mcgath would take leadership of the marlian forces
and because he was the former commander of the
ld and titan warrior unit he could also find a
way to help the marlin aldians eventually too but
as you can see Eren mikasa levi sasha armin aren't
having any of that Eren yeager is just like nope
i'm going to take all these titans i'm taking all
these powers home with me and even though they did
overhype it a little bit and it wasn't quite the
way you expected there were a couple big twists
with their fight the levi vs beast titan rematch
was awesome every time they fought in the past
levi has always done really really well surprising
zeke with his abilities but in previous seasons
levi's always had a problem taking him down and
making it stick usually something happens and
zeke gets away so there's a lot of backstabbing
and four-dimensional chests going on plots within
plots in this battle we'll have to wait to talk
about some of them till next week because some of
them are kind of spoilery if you've read the manga
please don't spoil what's going on here in the
comments i believe they'll reveal most of that by
next week's episode so we'll be able to talk about
everything pretty soon but not everything here is
playing out as it seems we finally find out what
happened to reiner and falco reiner had titan
shifted into the armored titan to protect falco
but it rendered him temporarily unconscious until
his powers can heal him back to 100 percent but
falco's arc here is a big deal this season and you
sort of see that begin right here in this moment
in that he's someone that goes from hating the
ldns just listening to all the rhetoric that the
marlians give them all the kool-aid that they pour
down their throats the lies that they tell them
about the history of the eldians and the titans
then he sees everything that reiner goes through
how he begged Eren to kill him he was so sick of
himself and what he was doing and then how Eren
showed him mercy saying that they're all aldians
we're all the same so he's just starting down
this path to finding some common ground with the
other eldians that'll become a much bigger deal
later this season and is juxtaposed with Gabi's
arc who's kind of going in the opposite direction
to that right now she's beginning to hate eldians
more and more and more just this blood thirst for
revenge then porco and peak are watching as Eren
tries unsuccessfully to bite through the warhammer
titan crystal it's so tough that it literally
destroys his jaw trying to eat through it but
surprises everyone when he tightens shifts into
another attack titan on the spot the thing about
this is the other titan warriors have no idea what
Eren's limits are and he's so well practiced
in doing things like this that he's a badass
but no matter how hardcore they are like even zeke
has his own limits in his titan powers eventually
their bodies their regular human bodies will just
give out and eventually even if he wanted to Eren
wouldn't be able to tighten shift but that's where
you have characters like peak who are way more
experienced in battle and just tell porko to chill
out like just wait this is a battle of attrition
we have them completely surrounded they don't have
any backup because they don't know about the big
surprise waiting in the bay and they don't know
about the zeppelin with hange so like i said just
more big twists unfurling four-dimensional chests
throughout the episode he finally starts talking
about the rumbling again the rumbling that they're
talking about is them finding out that Eren yeager
plans to actually make good or they think that
he plans to make good on the threat that the
old eldian king of paradise made to marley 100
years ago that he would unleash the hundreds of
colossal titans that made up all the walls and
literally have them trample the entire earth
till everything was destroyed everything i'll
talk about this again in a second too when i
talk about the colossal titan in the bay but when
he's walking through after he destroys all the
ships you see all that carnage the red glow of the
battlefield you have to imagine after the rumbling
the entire earth would look like that you guys can
also let me know what you think of mapa's redesign
of the colossal titan ii obviously it looks like
a very different character model than the earlier
seasons in the colossal titan but this is them
positioning Eren as the enemy of all mankind at
the moment we'll see if he winds up going through
with it though because there's still a long ways
away from the actual final issues of the manga and
the anime at least as i'm posting this video right
now at the end of january so there are way more
twists in the story than i'm expecting before we
get to actual finale then we actually get the
full colossal titan twist in the bay when the
marley and ships are trying to coordinate their
attack until they notice a tiny little sailboat
just slipping through them hey like wait a minute
what's that what's going on here and then boom
armin titan shifts destroying the entire fleet so
that marley can't turn right around and retaliate
immediately against parodies that's the whole
reason to have armin destroy all the ships in the
bay because they have a giant fleet they be able
to take all their forces and earlier peak was just
hyping up just how much more powerful marley's
army was than parodies there's no way they could
beat us in a regular war anyway well they can't
even have a war if they can't actually get on
the ships to get to parodies so that's the eldian
forces just giving themselves time to get ready
for that armin gets all philosophical starting to
think about bertolt like i wonder if this is what
bertolt felt like when he's destroying all this
stuff armin is kind of having the same reaction
to all this that mikasa had last week when she
was like Eren what are you doing here you're
killing all these women and children in Eren's
like yeah that's cool just hold on a second i
gotta go grab some more titan powers so there will
be a big reckoning for Eren in next week's episode
when he's finally reunited with the rest of the
eldians sasha is able to help disable the cart
titan and then the rest of them take it down with
their thunder spears although they're able to save
peak so the kart titan is one of the few titan
powers that Eren is not able to get during the
episode surprisingly then hange finally re-enters
the battle in their support zeppelin guided by
lights that have been carefully installed along
the tops of the marlin buildings so it gives you a
better idea for just how long their plan had been
in motion and how deep this goes because it would
have taken them a long time to set that up and
they would have needed a lot of help from inside
marley so clearly there are confederates working
with them inside the marlin army we'll learn more
about that in future episodes too then pretty
much the last 10 minutes of the episode is just
one twist right after the other poor goat sees the
zempel and tries to take it out but mikasa chops
his legs right off and Eren rips his arms off to
prevent him from attacking then gets the bright
idea after seeing him scratch the crystal to use
him as the world's most nutcracker to get at that
sweet sweet juicy center you gotta love willy's
sister's reaction as this is all happening too
like she thinks she's all safe inside her crystal
like you're never gonna get inside here to wait a
minute what are you doing why are you using the
jaw titan like that please please don't do that
Eren drinks down the powers of the warhammer titan
making himself that much more powerful and he's
on his way to consuming the jaw titan at least
until reiner titan shifts into the armor titan
i'll talk about that in a second too but now
he'll have the powers of five different titans
at the same time so he has the base attack titan
the founding titan that his father also gave him
the armored titan powers because of the spinal
fluid that he ingested during season three
he was able to integrate some of the
powers of the armored titan into his
own during that if you consume the spinal fluid
of some of the other titans you can incorporate
their powers into your own at least some of them
not all their powers though in order to get all
the powers of their titan you'd have to consume
them whole the old-fashioned way titan powers
number four and five are now the warhammer titan
powers he has all of those and he'll get the jaw
titan powers pretty quickly as well collecting all
those titan powers like their pokemon or something
the last real big moment of the episode though
this big reiner armor titan moment is that as Gabi
and Falco are screaming at the top of their lungs
for him to come help them out and join the fight
he quietly says why won't they just let me die
in peace so he does tighten shift but not because
he wants to help them survive because he's hoping
that Eren will kill him and end his suffering but
next week we'll see if gabi is able to get some
revenge and find out what everyone does with Eren
once they finally bring him back into the fold
Eren you have some explaining to do but if there's
anything from the episode that i didn't talk about
in the video or big easter eggs that you noticed
just write them below in the comments in my attack
on titan season 4 episode 7 video we'll post next
sunday just like normal and just in terms of the
total episode count because we're so far away from
the finale and they're going so slowly through
the manga at this point i definitely think there's
gonna be some sort of season four part two like a
second block of episodes or some series of movies
that they do to wrap everything up but there
will be more story after the 16 episodes that
are listed on the wiki right now like that won't
be it there's just no way they're going to try and
speed run the entire rest of the manga within 16
episodes everyone click here for that brand new
godzilla vs kong trailer video and click here
for my attack on titan season 4 episode 6 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!